[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravier de vous retrouver
pour ce premier débat de l'année nous
parlerons ce soir des fameuses vignettes
critères vous l'avez peut-être sans
doute déjà commandé tout automobiliste
peut la poser sur son pare brise
alors je dis bien peut être imposée car
la vignette critère n'est pas
obligatoire en france elle permet
simplement de reconnaître et de classer
les véhicules en fonction de leur
pouvoir de pollution c'est en fait un
outil à destination des communes qui
pourront facilement adapter la
circulation les jours de pollution
elles peuvent par exemple interdire une
catégorie de véhicules dans des zones de
circulation restreinte ce sera le cas à
paris ou la pose de la vignette sera
obligatoire à partir du 16 janvier
prochain il vous faudra débourser tout
de même un peu plus de 4 euros
alors si certains se félicite de
l'arrivée de cet outil en faveur d'une
meilleure qualité de l'air d'autres
dénoncent une mesure inappropriée avec
nous pour en débattre
daniel guerreau vous êtes président de
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes
olivier paréja vous êtes conseiller
municipal europe ecologie les verts à
guyancourt bonsoir messieurs olivier
paréja avec cette vignette critères le
gouvernement ressuscite en fait la
pastille verte
c'est un mois daniel guerreau oui
excusez moi oui c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas forcément nouveau je dirais
que c'est même plus compliqué que ça
l'était à l'époque parce qu'il y avait
effectivement cette pastille verte
on s'aperçoit que c'est une énième
mesure qui fait suite à 15 ans de la
politique égoïste appareils et sans
effets de la part de la mairie de paris
égoïste pourquoi parce que finalement on
a deux millions d'habitants au sein
d'une région qui fait 12 millions
d'habitants et on voudrait faits qui
m'ont prendre des mesures qui soient en
interne à la mairie de paris et est à
paris et en ignorant tout ce qui se
passe autour
alors pourquoi elle est appareils parce
que souvent on fait des coups à paris à
la mairie de paris est sans effet parce
qu'on voit que finalement même la
circulation alternée qu'on a mis en
place et pas très longtemps
ça n'a pas eu grand j'ai fait à tenir
aux us
demant la circulation alternée ça a été
décrit comme peu efficace ça ça
permettrait en ciblant les véhicules
pollueurs d'améliorer justement elle est
recrutée il ya eu une expérience
grandeur nature qui vient d'être fait à
grenoble et après all c'est parce que si
vous prenez le journal local qui
s'appelle grrrr net c'est le grenoble
net et qui est datée du 15 décembre
on vous dit qu'il ya eu aux jours de
pics de pollution à grenoble on a mis en
place et testée cette vigne est restée
critères et sept jours après il y avait
toujours autant de pollution ou voire
pire tous à venir finalement on attribue
tous les maux à la voiture alors que la
pollution la voiture extrêmement mineure
d'ailleurs on voit bien que la pulsion
ce bal je bosse je balade je pourrais
vous montrer des cas alors mineurs
attendent et on va faire réagir olivier
paris ja là dessus quand même une étude
a dit que 51% des particules fines de
moins de 2,5 micromètres provenait du
trafic routier
alors effectivement on va pas rentrer
dans les différents types de particules
de polluants etc
mais on pourrait en gros dire que par
rapport à l'air pollué il y en a un
tiers qui vient de l'automobile un tiers
qui vient du chauffage individuel ou ou
industrielles donc ça veut dire que la
part de l'automobile c'est pas le seul
facteur mais c'est un facteur important
et on voit les les décisions récentes à
paris là pendant les vacances de noël ou
le chauffage au bois a également été
interdite donc en fait il ya plusieurs
facteurs
et l'idée c'est de s'attaquer à tous ces
facteurs donc mettre des vignettes et
empêcher la circulation des voitures
pendant les pics de pollution
c'est nécessairement pas la solution
c'est un palliatif il faut bien faire
quelque chose il ya une étude qui dit
qu'il ya quand même 48 mille morts
prématurés dus à la pollution de l'air
donc il est nécessaire de faire quelque
chose c'est pas la seule mesure c'est
d'une efficacité
on va peut-être être d'accord là dessus
c'est d'unifier cas cités avant cela
demandera dessus donc c'est petit coeur
mais ce n'est pas sûr vraiment non j'ai
pas dit ça j'ai dit que ça peut pas être
la mesure
en fait c'est la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder le vase
donc à un moment le vase il est plein et
il est plein parce qu'il ya tout un tas
de politiques qui ne sont pas menés au
bout par exemple les transports en
commun nécessairement on pourrait
imaginer et en particulier en ile de
france c'est vrai dans d'autres régions
mais en particulier en ce qui nous
concerne en ile de france
on paye quand même des années de nos
investissements sur les transports en
commun mais c'est le grand paris prévoit
un investissement assez important dans
la loire dans les transports en commun
ça va prendre des années et ça va pas
régler le gros problème qui est la
fiabilité des transports actuels sur la
ligne aura duré rer par exemple donc il
ya quelque chose qu'il faut absolument
faire c'est inciter les automobilistes à
aller vers des transports en commun il
faut qu'ils soient plus fréquents il
faut qu'ils soient moins chers
éventuellement pourquoi ne pas penser à
la gratuité des transports en commun on
n'est pas obligé de l'appliquer que
pendant les pics de pollution donc la
vigne est une solution parmi d'autres à
réfléchir
daniel guerreau quand même cette
pollution vous la subissez aussi vous
êtes un habitant de l'agglomération
est ce que l'idée n'est pas bonne au
fond écoutez on parlait de la semaine
dernière j'ai vu la semaine dernière
c'était les vacances il y avait très peu
de voitures qui roulaient et pourtant il
y avait un pic de pollution donc on voit
que cette mesure
elle est pratiquement inefficace et on a
parlé des transports en commun justement
le transport de l'île de france on dit
mais on va pu mettre des transports
gratuits parce que ça nous coûte 4
millions d'euros par jour
la dernière fois ça a coûté 20 millions
et 20 millions pour acheter des trains
neufs achetés transports en commun des
bus neufs donc ce serait mieux employé
que d'essayer de prendre cette mesure
qui est certes spectaculaire qui lui
fait dire on a nos dirigeants voyez on
fait quelque chose pour vous mais ça
n'apporte pas grand chose finalement
et vous parlez des transports en commun
c'est bien mais transports en commun ne
règle pas tout moi j'habite ici par
exemple à saint quentin en yvelines si
je veux aller à tamar ou anthony cheveux
bien obligés de tourner une voiture je
dois d'aller par la route je crois qu'il
faudrait un plan d'eau sentent comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure on a finalement
fait des coups pendant 15 ans sans
véritable ligne de conduite
mais il faudrait effectivement amélioré
tout ce qui est transports il faudrait
aussi et la route reste un des éléments
de déplacement qui est fondamental
que si on va aller de banlieue à
banlieue il faut le faire peut-être par
covoiturage il faut le faire peut-être
par auto partage mais il faut le faire
peut-être par des et par des voies
dédiées donc la route reste un élément
extrêmement important quand j'ai fait un
débat il ya pas longtemps il mâchonne
nadjovski de la mairie de paris
il veut absolument plus qu'on investisse
dans les infrastructures routières
absolument plus qu' on essaie de faire
sauter les bouchons c'est quand même un
non sens parce que demain on aura des
voitures propres plus propre et il faut
bien faire des infrastructures donc il
faut offrir plutôt que de punir et
d'interdire pour offrir des solutions
alors allez-y sur l'efficacité via
m'instruire tokyo une grande métropole
où il y avait énormément de circulation
et en particulier du diesel dans les
années 2000 tokyo a fait l'objet de
mesures pour réduire la circulation et
en particulier la circulation des
diesels et l'effet sur la santé des
habitants a été démontrée donc c'est
quand même ces mesures c'est quand même
pas quelque chose qui inventaient comme
vous l'avez dit par la mairie de paris
exclusivement c'est quelque chose qui se
fait ailleurs les zones de restriction
circulation et en allemagne il y en a un
en italie y en a dans d'autres pays en
europe
c'est quand même quelque chose vers
lequel on tend et il ya de plus en plus
de métropole alors je dîne métropole je
suis d'accord avec vous si on habite
dans un dans une partie isolée et qu'il
faut rejoindre le transport en commun le
plus propre le plus près ça va être
nécessairement être difficile mais dans
les zones denses comme les métropoles
on peut imaginer avoir d'autres
solutions développées aussi des
circulations douces du type le vélo sur
saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui la politique de
l'agglomération n'est pas au niveau de
ce qu'il nous faudrait pour arriver à
rendre le vélo sur décider si des
distances courtes de l'ordre de 6 km le
vélo est plus efficace que la voiture
donc s'est déversée solution-là de
transport en commun de multimodal qu'il
faut aller je suis d'accord sur le fait
que le punitif n'est pas la solution
mais il ya un énorme investissement à
faire pour essayer de développer de la
multimodalité peut-être de la voiture
pour se rapprocher d'une gare puis après
sur une gare et des choses de ce type là
alors je voudrais juste préciser pour
noter spectateurs que cette vie net
n'est pas obligatoire donc quand on
parle de punitif en réalité on va pas
être verbalisés
pour le non port de la vigne est un
apparat paris à partir du 16 janvier
prochain où effectivement il faudra
porter cette cette vignette fin que le
vix qui sort d'une restriction de
circulation
oui je voudrais revenir sur tous
connaissent et occupons-nous 6 2 500
arrête parce qu'aujourd'hui le diesel
est devenue un dogme
le diesel serait quelque chose qu'il
faut absolument bannir mais tokyo vous
savez quand même que depuis la norme
euro 6
on a réintroduit à tokyo les voitures
diesel ne serait ce qu'avec des masses
de la norme euro 6 elles ont même des
subventions parce qu elle ne l avais de
moins de co2 mais entre part comparé
enfin le sait de lui le diesel sésame
toxicité et sur l'inox donc memoria
surface sur le diesel à tokyo donc ça
c'est une réalité vous pouvez le
regarder
maj grave rend à nouveau des diesels à
tokyo et il a même des subventions pour
chaque fois qu'on a un certain nombre de
dogmes aujourd'hui et vous parler
effectivement du vélo c'est intéressant
le vélo mais ça n'est pas pour tout le
monde c'est à dire vous avez des
personnes de 75 ans quand il pleut vous
les mettez sur un vélo non je crois que
c'est sur ce que j'ai dit j'ai dit qu'il
fallait favoriser le fait d'avoir
plusieurs ou moyen de transport le fait
de passer de l'un à l'autre facilement
et ça demande des infrastructures que
l'on n'a pas aujourd'hui
et j'aimerais aussi revenir sur quelque
chose la vignette a aussi un avantage
c'est comme quand on va acheter un
frigidaire et que l'on voit l'étiquette
rouge orange verte ça va aussi permettre
d'informer je dis pas que ça va être
coercitif l'insa valtteri les autorités
savent ah non ça va permettre d'informer
l'utilisateur de la voiture se dire dans
quelle catégorie aujourd'hui il faut
aller regarder sur sa carabine lendemain
un devoir civique ça c'est que les gens
à se dire je dis bonne conscience si
j'ai la vignette avec le shimano
chaussée juste de l'information le
consommateur qui est aussi qui fait
partie aussi des gens comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure qui va subir la
pollution les cent mille personnes qui
habitent autour du périphérique parisien
on peut pas les considérer que c'est
punitif d'empêcher les voitures de
passer au pied de chez eux quelque part
quand même il ya des enjeux de santé et
donc quelque part dans la dans le
l'acte d'achat d'une automobile ou de
rachat d'une automobile on peut imaginer
que c'est ce facteur là affichée sera
d'une certaine influence le maire de
grenoble d'années quand on dit qu'un
décès sur trois serait du parti et
derniers pensaient peut-être est gérée
dessus g15 la mairie de paris se bat
contre le diesel en plus
particulièrement donc cesser l'effusion
chercher mais c'est un conseil de le
lire le document qui vient d'être
publiée par monsieur jean de kervanous
et qui est l'ancien directeur des
hôpitaux de paris qui est spécialiste de
la santé de l'économie de la santé et
qui vous dit 43000 vos quarante mille
morts il a même kalika 3000 morts
pendant la semaine dernière on se bat
sur le mort ce sont des morts par
anticipation sont pas non plus exagérer
cela enfin c'est quand même faut pas de
la chance strand santé oui qui a sorti
cette année situation aujourd'hui quand
je fais des débats avec la mairie par un
drone mais il ya quarante mille morgan
un caddie 80 mille membres mais d'aller
à bord ni moi je prends vous jette des
jeux prend les décisions de lagence
français comme on donne l'impression que
quand on verra arriver à paris on va
tomber raide mort ce n'est pas du tout
la réalité au regard des analyses à
personne et brouillard et en chine où il
ya dix fois plus de pollution qu'un pari
en cinquante ans ils ont gagné 34 années
de durée de vie
donc la pollution c'est désagréable ça
nuit à la santé mais sur mes potes comme
on veut bien le dire non plus ceci dit
il faut lutter contre la population
contre la promiscuité
mais j'ai terminé juste parce que
finalement que j'étais d'une aube d'une
visite en 35 ans tami final si on peut
le populaire cette année deux corps
après l'échec qu'on regarde avec
finalement vous interdisez aux gens
modestes de rouler compas les moyens
d'acheter un véhicule récent
donc ce sont toujours les mêmes jeux qui
sont pénalisés on a interdit l'entrée
dans paris des véhicules de plus de 17
ans d'âge maintenant on veut encore
interdire aux gens de rouler parce
qu'ils sont modestes mais vous savez par
jean alesi l'attraction mois que les
personnes qui traversent paris les
études ont montré que les personnes qui
traversent paris ce ne sont pas les
personnes les plus modestes et que l'on
est que c'est plutôt des cadres seuls
dans leurs grosses voitures et qui plus
tôt une voiture récente
donc arretez de d'utiliser cet argument
là qui n'est pas vérifiée par l'analyse
caf et la mairie de paris sur l'être les
voitures qui traversent paris donc déjà
donné
le pari qu'on arrive à la fin du débat
pour conclure 30 secondes chacun
daniel guerreau allez-y oui ça peut
simplement dire que c'est un j'allais
dire c'est pratiquement un gadget de
plus qu'il ne résout pas les véritables
problèmes
il faudrait une véritable appelant dont
semble effectivement vous avez cité des
idées intéressantes à savoir des
parkings auprès des gars qui vont à
paris des parkings aussi aux portes de
paris
bon marché parce que moi confesse ma
voiture à la porte maillot pour aller
dans paris j'ai 35 euros de factures et
les gens modestes ne peuvent pas donc
tout ça ça s'organise
il faut aussi essayer d'éviter qui est
de plus en plus debout sont coupés sur
les voies sur berge est un non sens
total
comment expliquer aux gens qu'on
organise on dénombre eta jeu tour de son
cet endroit là on va améliorer la
qualité de l'air donc sa planque
d'ensemble pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'on ait une coupe plus mentalité
vous l'avais dit je le dis entre les
différents moyens de transport
c'est-à-dire offrir mais nous punir
olivier parent et jean le problème c'est
que on est obligés de faire quelque
chose à court terme on peut pas laisser
des pics de pollution s'installe et on
en a de plus en plus donc il faut bien
faire quelque chose donc à une mesure
palliative qui n'est pas la panacée mais
qui va permettre d'éviter d'aller trop
loin sur les piques
après effectivement c'est de
l'investissement c'est du développement
de transports en commun c'est changer de
mode de transport pour les petits
trajets et c'est ce genre de chose qui
va faire que demain on arrivera
peut-être à respirer correctement en ile
de france et d'ailleurs
plus généralement dans le reste de la
france voilà les deux opinions que nous
avions ce soir sur cette question des
vignettes critères merci nous avoir
suivis à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]